welcome back to cbs mornings we are
remembering the life and career of nba
hall of famer bill russell the boston
celtics legend died peacefully yesterday
he was 88 years old russell won 11 nba
championships and five mvp awards and
let's not forget he was also the nba's
first black head coach
he was not only a champion on the court
but also a champion of civil rights
marching with the reverend dr martin
luther king jr in the 1960s we spoke
with russell late last year in one of
his last and final tv interviews
[Music]
basketball hadn't seen anything like
bill russell before
when russell jumped russell soared
the kid from monroe louisiana who nobody
wanted on their team because of the
color of his skin he redefined what the
sport could be and eventually ended up
being the teammate no one could play
without bill this must been a great win
for you jack
russell catapulted the celtics and the
city of boston skyward in the 1950s and
60s winning titles and breaking barriers
at a time when keeping your dignity as a
black man in america was easier said
than done so we're sitting here in
boston
at the garden you helped bring glory
here
11 championships here what does it feel
like to be here
on this court
i never was uh
comfortable playing for the celtics
because the number one paper was the
boston herald and they didn't like the
idea
of the nba team having black players you
brought championships here in a time
when it was hard to be a black man was
it difficult
to be celebrated on the court
but then off of it
not treated equal
first of all i
was never separated on the court when i
got there was the star was bob cousy
watch boston's bob cruzy no matter what
i did because it was a star bill russell
another celtic caps it in i remember i
had a game where i had 25 points 25
rebounds 10 blocks and
boston harold said i was lucky i got to
play with cozy
i'm not a basketball player i am a man
who plays basketball bill russell the
man is someone who stood up for the
rights and dignity of all men
bill russell wasn't just an icon for
basketball fans
to rally behind on the floor of the
boston garden on any given night nine
top negro athletes meet with cassius
clay
he was an icon for black america using
his profile to highlight racism and
inequality
here with muhammad ali and other top
black athletes in 1967 backing ali's
decision refusing the vietnam war draft
at the march alongside dr king in
washington do you remember in kentucky
where you and your teammates set out
because they refused
service at a restaurant
yeah
at that time why did you feel like it
was important to do that well things are
part of our preparations for the game
the team would have
dinner together and i had a couple of
teammates from kentucky
and they were going to have a
separate pregame meal
so i told the coach i'm not going to
play tonight he said why not
i said cause of that
later that month this letter found its
way to russell's mailbox it was from
jackie robinson who broke major league
baseball's color barrier more than a
decade earlier thanking russell for
boycotting the game in kentucky jackie
was uh much more to him than most people
do
they just knew he was the first black
player in the major leagues
i mean they were good okay
but they didn't know he was uh probably
the most intelligent baseball player in
baseball wow and jackie would not take
anything off anybody i tried to get as
many as him i couldn't get there
which championship was the most special
to you was it the first one
or was it the last one the first year i
was player coach and we won the
championship first black coach in the
nba
is that right yeah
and you won as a player and a coach yeah
well you understand some my motivation
was to make myself acceptable to my
folks i never felt like i was making the
contribution
i was just doing the best i could
former president obama paid tribute to
russell on social media he wrote as tall
as bill russell stood his legacy rises
far higher both as a player and a person
perhaps more than anyone else bill knew
what it took to win and what it took to
lead
on the court he was the greatest
champion in basketball history off of it
he was a civil rights trailblazer those
are perfectly put words by former
president obama um you know he's such a
legend he accomplished so much on the
court
but
that pales in comparison to who he was
off of it right
and when at the time when players like
bill russell had a lot more to lose
it's much easier now i would argue in
2022 agreed than it was back when bill
russell and jackie robinson and muhammad
ali and kareem abdul-jabbar were playing
and michael jordan himself released a
statement when he said he set an example
for every black player that came into
the league including me michael jordan
and not just the players i look at this
table right now and i think if not for
people like bill russell yeah you know
there was a time we're putting two three
african-americans on television national
television on a morning show just you're
right we wouldn't be talking about it
and i have to say this and i'll be
honest when these young players come in
the league and they're blessed with
everything they're making millions
they're praised for what they do in
their sport
and they refuse to use their voice and
their platform for what's right
i think it's quite cowardly
because you had men and women doing it
in a time where it was tough because of
sometimes their life was at risk right
just because they stood up for what they
believed in so a lot of young players
they should look at individuals like
bill russell he will be remembered and
we'll talk about lead from him a little
bit later in the show as well